fantasy world heroes party adventurous
guilds magic spells demon lord demon
lord demon lord
fantasy stories have become the
mcdonald's chicken nugget of the anime
world now don't get me wrong i love
myself some cheeky nuggets but you can
be damn sure my body is crying the
morning after i stumble into mcdonald's
that one i am intoxicated and think 20
nugs sounds like a perfectly reasonable
amount of food to consume right now and
it is oh it always is even if we exclude
the
kai genre it feels like every world is
set in the same basic billy's first dnd
campaign without any slight variations
here and there like every so often we do
get something unique like um
what's what's the name again you know
the fantasy anime with that skull guy
no no no no like the skull guy was one
of the main characters
no no the other skull guy
no no he had a skull guy and there was
red hair
are you [ __ ] kidding me maggots
bright
it was magsprite
so to me it would be a complete surprise
if i found a story that had all these
usual elements present and yet somehow
immediately twisted it in a way i'd
never seen before while stamping out an
emotionally poignant hard-hitting tale
that nyon near brought a tear to my eye
within one chapter but that's exactly
what sorson or freyrin did freerun is
one of the most refreshing fantasy
stories i've read in a very long time
but before we jump to this fantasy world
you don't even need to travel far to try
snacks from a far away land thanks to
our friends over at boksu today's
sponsor box's monthly subscription
service that delivers premium japanese
snacks and tea pairings straight from
japan to your door each boxy features a
new theme providing a gourmet journey
through japan every single month boxes
of khani sent me this month's theme
which is midori moment which i am so
excited about because by far one of my
favorite things i've discovered after
moving to japan is that i love matcha
themed sweets and snacks all right let's
give it a try
[Music]
oh god oh my god that's so good oh [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] amazing oh that smells
so good
it's legit i think my favorite snack box
so far seriously guys if you haven't
tried any matcha flavored sweets before
you are missing out each box is packed
with snacks and comes with a cultural
booklet that tells you all about the
themes where the snacks come from
details on all the flavors and even
teaches you a few japanese words and
phrases if you want to try some awesome
japanese snacks and support this channel
click the link in the description and
use code giggup15 to get 15 off your
first boxu order thank you to boxy for
sponsoring today's episode and back to
soso no freerin or freerun beyond
journey then if you want the english
name or free run at the funeral if you
want the direct translated name or free
ren and the group of [ __ ] if you
want mine this is still the world of
billy's first dnd campaign but we
actually begin at the end of his
campaign because you see our hero party
has just gotten back from defeating the
demon lord you have your usual suspects
in the party returning home there's the
hero the priest the warrior and the elf
mage frieren our main character for this
story as they reminisce over the journey
they've just had they're greeted by a
meteor shower that comes once every 50
years and while they share an intimate
moment they make a promise to catch the
next one together in a better place the
guys wonder if they're even going to be
alive to see the next one by the time it
comes around and friends like
smell you later losers see you next
tuesday half a century passes in the
blink of an eye and when she returns she
once again reunites with a legendary
hero himmel the one who defeated the
demon lord once the most powerful man on
earth
now looks like that [ __ ] odd guy in
every anime sniffs panties for a living
yeah he may have defeated the demon lord
but he can't defeat time baby cause damn
time got hands reunited with the old
gang they once again go on one last
adventure to see the breathtaking meteor
shower before himmel eventually passes
away frieran at the funeral huh
huh initially seems like the same stoic
apathetic person she was before out of
nowhere she breaks down see they spent
10 years together which is an absolute
miniscule amount of time for an elf but
for a human it's anything but him also
saw her as a dear friend someone who he
shared a once in a lifetime experience
with who he spent a fair portion of his
life and time and companionship with but
to freeren himmel was just another
acquaintance she spent a bit of time
with one who she thought she would have
plenty of time to get to know better and
grow closer to and that's why she cries
not at the loss of losing a friend but
at the loss of the chance to truly see
him as one and that
phew god damn what a way to start
freerun has one of the strongest opening
chapters i've seen for our fantasy manga
the story comes charging out the gate
kicks you in the nutsack and leaves you
on the floor dribbling mess before you
can even make a deez nuts joke chapter
one could have easily been an emotional
one-shot but frieren uses it as a
springboard in order to begin her own
journey she doesn't know why such a
short period of time had such a huge
impact on her vast lifespan and so she
decides to retrace the steps her old
party went on in hopes of learning more
about the friends she knew so little
about the passing of time is obviously a
big theme in a story being told here and
a lot of it plays on how frion herself
perceives time being an elf means your
lifespan is functionally immortal
compared to us humans every elf you meet
despite their appearances would likely
be leagues older than you that's right
elves are just milfs in disguise
think about it for a second what i love
is that initially we see time from her
perspective years can pass in just a few
panels a page turn can result in a
decade being lost but that's what it
just feels like to her i mean she pissed
away 50 years like i pissed away 50
minutes playing a game of league of
legends now just imagine
how sad would you be if within that 50
minutes where your own for teemo mid was
flaming your useless yi jungle while
your bot lanes picked [ __ ] queen adc
and you were landing against tom kench
top you could have used that time to get
closer to a friend that cherished you
deeply before they died
[Music]
i'm already playing league there's no
going below rock bottom a life span of a
thousand plus years is so unimaginably
long for humans to be able to comprehend
as frieren goes on her journey we see
the effects of the different towns and
villages that were saved by the heroes
party and how the memories of what they
did were being preserved because even if
we were involved in an event as massive
as saving the world and defeating the
demon king life moves on after that
stories will get passed down statues
will persist but living memories of the
people who actually remember will only
remain for so long you see frieren deal
with problems that we would never even
begin to think about what happens when
all of your friends pass away and
there's no proof of what you did
together aside from the memories you
take with you how do you even begin to
build the same bonds when you know their
entire lives will be just a blip in
yours
alright this getting a little depressing
here's some action
one upside of being in the party that
defeated the demon king is that friend
kicks [ __ ] ass she was already strong
enough when she helped defeat the demon
lord but now she has even more time to
hone her magic frequently keeps getting
stronger and more powerful freerun
barely fears any monsters and her crew
sweeps up any trouble they encounter on
their journey freeren
it's not an action manga to come here
looking for that well there are some
fights here and there and as the manga
goes on an overarching plotline starts
to form about taking down some of the
remnants of the old demon lord's army
where the manga shines is in its quieter
introspective moments even though
frieren is probably older than any of us
will ever come close to reaching she
still feels like a naive kid in a lot of
ways often times she'll come off as
detached or uncaring and it's seeing her
slowly come to terms with what she's
been through processing her experiences
and the beautiful moments that come out
of it is what is right at the heart of
this tale i don't want to be that guy
that sits here and says it's kind of a
slow burn guys because to me slow burn
has always been the code for you
basically just said it's boring but in
cursive you pretentious hack but what i
found here is that there's such a unique
feeling that leaves you whenever you
finish a chapter and that's because of
the atmosphere it creates it's not a
series that sucks you in and refuses to
let go but instead it blossoms and
envelops you you get lost in its
ambience ambience ambiance ambiance god
damn it i am that pretentious hack which
is why i think this manga is screaming
for an anime adaptation it's rare to
find a manga that is able to set such a
strong atmosphere so i can only imagine
what it would be like with sound effects
voice acting music and motion to help
set that tone normally when i read a
manga i put my sonic shoes on [ __ ]
running of the 90s starts playing
because my eyes speed through these
panels but with freeren there are
several points with zero dialogue zero
reason to hold back and yet i found
myself slowing down my reading pace to
just give time for the tail to sink in a
bit more because it just felt
right there would be a line or two that
would come out of nowhere and just stick
with me like in one of these chapters
frieren meets a teenage boy named stark
who's the disciple of one of the members
of her hero party but also a coward he's
living in this village that's being
terrorized by a dragon and when frieren
asks him for help to get rid of it he
reluctantly says yes even though he's
terrified so when she asks him why he
would risk his life protecting this
village he replies it's simple he's
lived there for three years
frieren calls that ephemeral stark calls
it an eternity and i don't know why but
that one little line reminded me just
how different we view the passage of
time as we get older elf or not the
older you get the more time feels like
it speeds by and i don't know why just
that one line alone made me wallow in
the moment for a second of just what
time must feel like to a being like
frieran and it's little bits like this
that is the real beauty of this manga
when you read it there won't be this big
world shattering plot twist or this
dramatic character death that sticks out
to you sometimes a character will just
say a line that will make you pause for
a bit or you'll turn a page and just see
this panel where you just have to sit
there and absorb for a while chapters
are seeped in an era of melancholy
frieren would be reminiscing about the
party and i would be feeling nostalgic
over them even though i barely even knew
them but i suppose that's exactly how
she felt too we are told that elves in
this world are essentially endangered
species largely coming from their lack
of drives to seek out each other and
breed which makes sense for a species
having such an over abundance of time
can be a curse because when you have so
much of it how do you find the
motivation to make the most of it a
story like fririn shows us that it's not
just about the amount of time that
defines what will leave the biggest
impact on your life but the quality of
how you choose to spend it every chapter
starts off with a reminder of how many
years it's been since himmel's death
because even though the time she spent
with him on that journey was less than
even a hundredth of her lifespan that
short amount of time left an imprint
that will stay with her for the
remainder of it no no time is of equal
value and just because you have more of
it doesn't necessarily mean your life
will have a richer experience for
someone like freeren one year is barely
perceived ten years is merely a blip a
hundred years is a small phase but even
though someone like her possesses more
time than any of us will ever come close
to having it can pass her by just as
quickly if she's not careful about it
because it doesn't matter if you live
for 10 years 50 years 80 years or a
thousand years you can easily waste that
time all the same so keep that in mind
next time you're about to hit that match
accept button
but for [ __ ] sake
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much this month too alpha
sigma basil dysfunctional degenerate
elephant flabberwocky ivido jeff
levardos payne patchett pony stark
waltergeist fiti and everyone else my
patreon for helping to support me for
this month and making this video
possible just a quick update as you can
see i'm in my english office
not just because i'm getting married but
also because i'm going to be attending
mcm london that's right i'm going to be
attending mcm on the weekend of the 27th
i'm gonna be guessing there on the
saturday with the rest of the trash
taste boys so if you're coming and you
see me about come say hi i'll probably
have some panels and signings here and
there i'm probably going to be drinking
a few pies here and there as well anyway
though that's all i have to say today
i've been up and i'll see you all next
time